I got a lot of questions to be we're
gonna dive right in number one that rose
ceremony
were you sent home Kailyn why Cassie /
Kailyn I don't think that's a fair
question I think you could ask why Hanna
why Taoiseach and like a C / King and
one thing that I wish I could have
articulated more to Kailyn tonight was
it was nothing where our relationship
was it was where the others were so that
was like the one thing and I said it I
heard that was the hardest rose ceremony
that I had all season well you seemed
very drawn to Cassie I mean Kailyn and
told you I love you and you you stuck
with Cass even though you weren't clear
on her feelings why that's one thing
that I think people need to realize is
when you're in the relationship you have
to do and follow your heart and trust
your gut as much as possible it's really
easy for people to see the outside but
the feeling and the connection in the
chemistry I think is something that's
undeniable and you just have to sort of
follow all your art with it
[Music]